Hi everyone. My name is Soheil Feizi.
I'm founder and CEO at Rely. I'm also an
associate professor in the computer
science department at University of
Maryland.
Today I'm going to talk about continual
learning for AI agents. How we can go
from failures to durable improvements.
And if you're interested in any of the
tools that I'll be talking in this
presentation, you can visit at our web
at our website rely.ai.
Let's get this started.
Humans learn mainly from experience by
interacting with the world and getting
feedback.
The goal of continual learning is to
imitate the same for agents.
So they can also learn from experience
by acting, getting feedback, and
improving without forgetting.
All right. So here's basically a bigger
picture of how continual learning for
agents look like. So here's an agent
that interact with the world, with
diverse users, with complex tools,
uh with various data policies. And as I
mentioned, the goal is to continuously
improve the agent from its experience
without forgetting. And this learning
can happen in different layers of the
agent. It can happen in the model layer
where potentially we can change weights
of LLMs or other models used in the
agent, or use different types of models
in the agent. It can happen in the
harness layer where it brings the
context,
proper context to the LLM
uh with components like prompts, skills,
tools, code, workflow. And it can also
happen in the memory, either in session
memory or persistent memory of the
agent.
But there are two, I would say,
fundamental challenges in continual
learning for agents. The first challenge
is how to get feedback. How do we know
if the agent did well?
And if not, what should it have done
instead? That's basically the first
part, getting the feedback. And the
second part is how we can act upon that
feedback. How we can optimize and
improve agent and learn from that
feedback. Which layer, which component
do we need to change and also how.
I'll be talking about these two
challenges, current approaches in order
to deal with them and also provide some
perspective of how we think about these
two problems.
So, let's get it started with the first
problem.
Where does the feedback come from?
So, the easy case is when we have a
benchmark and some evaluators on that
benchmark. So, the agent can run tasks
from the benchmark. Now, we have the
evaluators in order to score and we can
get grades like pass, fail, or reward,
as well as potentially some feedback on
the agent behavior and agent
performance. This is usually what is
happening during the development time
that different teams they curate
benchmarks in order to understand the
performance of the agent in certain
applications.
But in production, we don't have such
benchmark. We have logs. Here's an
example of a session log where a user is
interacting with the agent. Maybe the
user is not very happy with the way way
the agent is behaving, but we don't have
any explicit feedback. So, there are two
ways of getting such feedback
on such session logs. One is automatic
using some other models or LLMs or code
in order to analyze the log and provide
feedback. In some cases, even the agent
itself can look at it is log and provide
some critics of it.
It is automatic and it is scalable.
And the second approach is where we have
human experts to look at some handful of
these logs and provide some domain
expert expert feedback on those
agent outputs.
Uh this is lower in the volume, but it
is critical because it provides expert
knowledge on the behavior of the agent
and its is alignment with the way that
we want agent to behave in those
applications. Either way, now we have
session log plus some feedback on those
logs. Is it enough?
The answer is no because it is still not
testable.
Here we have log and feedback, but what
we really need is a replayable learning
environment, a simulation that we can
rerun with defined grading on what
success looks like, not one instance of
what happened and the feedback on top of
it.
So what is a learning environment? Here
we are inferring a distribution
from one observation that replaces what
happened and what success means.
Uh the input is what we have some
session logs and feedback. This is
basically one observation of what
happened and now we want to create a
simulation and evaluation environment
from that information that involves, for
example, understanding how tools in the
agent
behavior in the agent log should behave,
should we use real tools, should we use
mock tools, and if so, what kind of data
brought to the mocking process of those
those tools.
If the agent is interacting with some
users,
how we can infer synthetic users from
that data.
And also how success looks like in that
learning environment. What are the
evaluators that needs to be inferred. So
there are lots of technical challenges
in any of these components, but if we
could do this successfully, they could
use this the output as executable. We
can now run different candidates of the
agents against such learning
environment, understand the behavior and
the performance of the agent in those
scenarios and in those patterns, and we
can fix the issues
um based on the feedback, based on the
information that we observe because now
everything becomes testable and
verifiable.
All right. So, the second problem is
now we have this feedback, how we can
act upon it, how we can optimize the
agent.
And
from a high-level point of view, there
are three layers that we can improve the
agent.
Uh there's a model layer where we can
change the weights of the model, and
there are methods like SFT, so
supervised fine-tuning,
uh RL-based post-training in order to
make those changes. And these are
usually expensive because that requires
uh more intensive compute in terms of
changing the model weights.
The second layer is the harness layer,
harness engineering, context
engineering, where we can potentially
pre-write prompts, maybe learn some
skills, uh change tools or add tools,
maybe change code around around the LLM,
and there are different methods like get
past race to harness, uh which provides
a lot of flexibility in terms of
learning from that feedback. And the
last layer is the memory layer, where we
store facts and learn skills uh in order
to not repeat those issues uh and
failures in in the future. But a good
learning is not going to be focusing on
any of these components exclusively. A
good learning engine should ask for the
smallest durable change at the right
layer of the agent.
All right. So, let me uh
dig a little bit deeper into each of
these layers.
So, first in terms of updating the model
weights, there are various approaches uh
in order to do that, uh including SFT,
supervised fine-tuning, where we imitate
correct trajectories. Uh we often need
labeled samples in order to um
fit those samples, uh fit the model to
those samples.
Other approaches are based on RL, um
reinforcement learning post-training,
like DPO, GRPO, RLV R, where we sample
score against the reward or preference
signals, and reinforce what wins. And
there are some categories based on LoRA,
low-rank adaptation, that limits the set
of parameters that can potentially
change. It makes this uh the learning in
this layer cheaper, and also safer um in
terms of the updates. But these methods,
they usually need benchmarks and
explicit evaluators. They cannot be
directly applied on, let's say, if you
have a log and feedback, unless we turn
those into uh replayable learning
environments.
Right, in terms of uh updating the
harness,
uh I would highlight the two uh
categories in in this domain, in this
layer. One is trace-to-harness
approaches. Let's say you observe a log,
you have some feedback on top of it, you
can effectively ask a coding agent in
order to analyze the log and improve the
agent.
So, this works on uh the case where we
have log and feedback, but it is
wipe-based. We don't know if even
for that particular uh sample, if the
change is effective, because it is not
testable. And we don't know what is the
impact of it on other samples and other
scenarios. What uh might have been
working previously, but with these
changes might not work properly, and
create some hidden regressions.
The other category that I want to
highlight is methods like GEPPO and
prompt search where they mutate prompts,
they score different candidates, and
they keep the winners using some search
algorithms like evolutionary algorithms.
And these are These methods are
testable, but they need a benchmark and
explicit evaluators in order to have
those
have those scorings.
And in the memory layer,
we effectively write down facts and we
distill skills so the agent doesn't
rediscover them. It can happen in the
information
memory layer, methods like LETA and
MemZero where they can effectively store
a fact or correction.
And we have also methods to skill
distillation that compresses successful
trajectory into reusable how-to do skill
for the for the agent. So, this
layer in terms of the update is cheapest
and fastest. It works directly on the
cases where you only have log and
feedback, but usually it is unverified
because you don't
have a way in order to test whether or
not
writing in the memory will resolve the
issues that you have dealt with and
whether or not it can potentially
create some regressions on some other
cases. With that, let me introduce a new
subcategory of continual learning called
verifiable continual learning.
In a verifiable continual learning, the
goal is to improve an agent from its his
own experience where every fix is proven
to help and proven to break nothing that
already worked.
And usually it involve it involves three
steps.
Where we need to have an executable test
where the failure becomes a task you can
replay and create.
Then we need to have a measured delta
where the update is scored on the test
before and after. And then we have a
regression test. So prior test still
pass even after we make such changes to
the agent.
So let's think about what are the
principles of a practical verifiable
continual learning first.
And I will argue there are four
important principles that we need to
keep in mind.
So the first principle is replayability.
We need to turn a one of failure into a
test that we can rerun. Here, as I had
mentioned previously, many cases we have
log and feedback, but that is not
testable. We need to
lift it in a
learning environment to simulate and
evaluate the agent on a similar pattern
on a similar scenario. So everything
becomes testable
based on that simulation and evaluation
environment. So that's basically the
first principle that we need to have.
The second principle is holisticness.
One failure may have several causes and
several possible repairs. You know, let
me give you an example. Let's say you
have an agent that cites a stale policy
and skips the required escalation. The
issue might come from the memory where
you have some stale fact. It can come
from
uh not optimized prompt. It might come
from a tool that doesn't normalize the
policy. Might come from the workflow
that we need to add escalation gate
before we run. It might come from the
model. Maybe the model is not a good
model in order to have a strong
reasoning.
So here we need to route the fix to the
right layers that explains the failure
with the smallest durable change to the
agent. And that is basically the
principle of holisticness in verifiable
continual learning.
The third principle is lifelongness. A
new fix must improve the new case
without breaking the past. Let's
consider the setup where we already
optimize the agent on K past learning
environments and a new failure comes and
we turn that into a learning environment
EK plus one.
What do want to change? So, the first
approach is okay, just focus on this new
learning environment,
but that can create regression on the
past behavior on the past learning
environments that the agent was
successful.
A better approach is a regression aware
learning where the regression is not be
treated as a post-hoc approach, but as a
mechanism
within the optimization itself. So, here
we are uh fixing the recent failures
subject to having no regression on the
past uh learning environments.
And obviously, this needs to be done in
a efficient manner, so it doesn't scale
even linearly with K because K can grow
and the complexity of this approach can
uh can uh
can be very can be very high.
And the last
but not least principle is the
efficiency.
This continual learning loop needs to
run frequently
and we need to have efficiency in uh
different layers in updates to the
agent.
So, sometimes the
change can be cheap, like for example,
writing something in the memory can be
medium in terms of the complexity by
changing the prompt or hardness,
and sometimes it can be very expensive
by
changing the weights of the model.
Also, efficiency should be in the
optimization loop itself, especially
when we have regression aware
optimization and regression is treated
within the loop
not as a post hoc approach.
To sum up, these are the four principles
of a practical verifiable continual
learning. Replayability,
holisticness, lifelongness, and
efficiency.
And this is what we have
been working on at Rely to create a
verifiable continual learning engine for
AI agents based on these four
principles.
In particular, here's how Rely's
learning loop runs.
You can start with some signals to
this loop. It can be logs, feedback, or
even instructions and prompts.
We lift those in those signals to
replayable learning environments. So,
that's
based on the replayability principle.
This makes everything that follows
testable and verifiable.
Then we do root cause analysis and route
the fixes to the right layer of the
agent. It can be memory, it can be
model, or it can be harness.
That touches the holisticness principle
that I described.
We have regression aware optimization.
Regression is not being treated as a
post hoc approach, so that touches the
lifelongness
principle that I mentioned. And
obviously, this loop should run
efficiently. That touches the efficiency
principle.
So, the output of this is a reviewable
version update to the agent explaining
what changes in the agent during this
loop and why those changes are
are improving the agent without creating
regression.
The beauty of it is you can
add a VCL verifiable continual learning
to your current agent in just two
comments.
So, the first one is a one-time setup.
You create a learning harness in your
agent.
You can use your own LLM and your
agent can be built on top of any of
available major agent frameworks.
And then after that, you need two
commands in order to activate this
learning loop. You can create learning
environments using various type of
signals that you can have either
log log feedback or some instructions,
and then you can call to like optimize
in order to use holistic lifelong
optimizer to improve the agent. And the
output is a optimized version pull
request that you can review and you can
use it in order to improve your agent.
So, let's look at the how it actually
works in practice. We build a
continual learning benchmark on a
fictional
support agent case
where we have reproducible test beds for
continual learning in a tool using
support agent.
So, we have a single source of truth and
the policies are interacting for this
agent to be handling. So, we have
deterministic evaluators
and we also build this benchmark in a
way that it has some regression trap.
So, if the optimizer focuses on
overfitting on the latest fix, it can
potentially break
what are what the agent was previously
successful on other tasks.
So, let's say we have an agent.
We don't even have logs or anything, and
we want to just see how the agent is
behaving. Uh, let's say when um,
caller is rude and adversarial. So,
simply we can create a learning
environment using such instruction.
And what it will do, it will create a
learning environment to simulate and
evaluate the agent.
Uh,
the simulator will include personas,
intent, mock, uh, or real tools and also
the learning environment contain
evaluators in order to define success
metrics.
All of these are produced from just one
interactive comment.
And after that, we can just simulate the
agent using this learning environment,
see how it behaves. Okay, the score is
uh, not too uh, high. It is 78% and in
particular, there are two
um, evaluators that uh,
basically show very low scores uh, of
agent in this environment.
So, these are some of the failures that
we observe. How to improve such
failures? We can do that by calling Rely
Optimize with certain number of
rollouts. And as you can see, the
average improvement uh, can be um,
quite high. Uh, it is 10% improvement on
average just with one loop and score
increases to 97% from 87%.
Okay, now let's consider the case that
now the agent is in production. Now, you
have a log, you have an agent session
that isn't um,
not desired and you have a feedback. For
example, you can say keep fast eligible
refunds, but do not generalize
generosity beyond refund thresholds. So,
that's a feedback on the agent behavior.
Again, the flow is the same, so we lift
it into a replayable learning
environment and we call Rely Optimize in
order to mitigate this uh, issue. Use
this feedback without creating
regression of the agent behavior in past
environments.
And this is lifelong, so you can keep
doing that uh to improve the agent
without breaking what already works, and
it is compounding. This is verifiable
continual learning in practice, where
each update is tested, every gain is
measured, and nothing that already works
breaks during this optimization.
So, that's it for uh today and for this
talk. So, there are three key takeaways
that I want to highlight. The first one
is agent continual learning is not
necessarily model fine-tuning. The
updates and many useful updates can
happen in the harness and memory layer.
So, the second takeaway is production
logs are not learning environments. We
need to transform them into replayable
learning environments to simulate and
evaluate the agent on the same patterns
and scenarios.
And the third takeaway is that the
frontier is regression-aware continual
improvement, where when fixing the new
failure, we verify that we don't forget
the old ones. We don't create
regression. So, that's verifiable
continual learning built on four
principles: replayability, holisticness,
lifelongness, and efficiency.
And if you want to try um
our VCL and apply it to your agent, you
can use it today at rely.ai. Thank you.